our second speaker is professor team
clay from the
department of statistics and data
science at
cmu and the jing
got his phd in 2010 you know it's peter
and i remember yesterday uh jeff
mentioned he is number 16
of peter's students
and
is a number 32 so i don't know what the
number was
rachel oh you got it i looked up
yesterday it's 57 or 50 seconds okay so
rachel doesn't know first yet so it's
been interesting to find out all of
those kind of numbers
so yeah florence justin thank you thank
you haiyan for the introduction thank
the organizers lisa for for making this
happen and also thank peter for the
support and
all the education the inspiration
through the years so i'm going to
deliver you to another
talk on network inference
this work is is uh done with the help of
my former student at cmu kevin lynn and
currently a postdoc at upenn with
working with nancy
so uh i guess at this point we are we're
fairly familiar with network data
from the talk yesterday and the the the
one from rachel so uh uh
again we will be focusing on studying
the community structure
in networks and this time it's like the
motivation is more from the biological
side
rather than from the social science
and
you may wonder how how did i
become interested in studying networks
of course
this paper has appeared on
on a screen yesterday and this paper was
published in 2009
and i was
peter's uh i guess one of the most
senior phd students at that time so i
had the luck
to help peter latex up all the talks
so in addition to the
to the group meetings and and i also had
the chance to just uh
see over like the year and a half how
this work evolved and
and i learned a lot from this
so the
in this work we will consider
multi-layer network data and here's an
example of gene code expression maybe i
should have taken this off the gene code
expression
networks taken from
this medial prefrontal cortex of
recessed monkeys and this
area of brain is known to be connected
to
uh recognition disorders like autism and
i learned about this data and this
problem from my my colleague testing
radar at cmu so what we're seeing is
that like in the entire
network there are about 8 000 genes and
i'm only plotting a subset of them
through three different time points and
we can see that
we we can see some block structure from
time to time and roughly the there are
four blocks we can see like visually
from these three time points there's
first block and the second and the third
block is it and the fourth one is are
visible at the second time point but if
you only look at one time points for
example the first one the third and the
second they they are somehow in distinct
indistinguishable and that the second
time point the first and the second they
are less distinguishable so we really
need to aggregate the information across
different time points to recover these
essentially consensus or common
group structures
so the question is how do we aggregate
and
how
how
does having these multiple layers of
network
facilitate our inference
okay so
to
to mathematically describe this problem
i will consider what we call a
multi-layer stochastic block model and
we we just saw single layer stochastic
block model from ratio stock so here the
the uh the difference is that like in
addition to have only one i have many of
them called capital l
and
these b matrices are just for each level
the community wise
edge probability matrices so they have
entries between zero and one and they're
symmetric
and um
and all these layers they share the
common membership vector g so with with
each entry being one through k integers
so now uh it's just this is just a
multi-layer version of the adjacency
matrix generation so for layer l
entry i j is generated from bernoulli
row times the corresponding
membership wise
edge probability
layer l and here this row
is usually a small number
controlling the global level of sparsity
of the edges so the goal is observe
after observing these l multiple layer
adjacency matrices how do you estimate
the g so here we view g not as a random
vector from a multinomial but
it's it's a fixed parameter
of length and
okay so uh the case of single layer when
l equals one is is very well understood
um
it's the it has almost 40 years of
history in the literature and the
community recovery is
studied by many people i believe in this
room perhaps 70 percent at least
have written paper on this topic so it's
impossible for me to list all the
references
so
one thing we we all know is that like in
the simplest case when when there's a
constant number of communities and the
group size are balanced and the
consistent estimation meaning that like
only a vanishing proportion
of nodes are misclustered and
if
this is possible only if this
average node degree diverges
okay so now one question we will
consider today is how will this multiple
layer because we now have more data
because we have more layers how does
this capital l the number of layers come
into play in this problem
okay so um
there are quite a few
papers in this direction so and and this
line of work starts from what we call
this layer wise positivity assumption
so essentially if you assume that all
these layers the the connectivity matrix
b
they are positive definite
smallest eigenvalue bounded away from
zero then what you can do is you can
just
one simple is just to add them up so
that you can you can imagine that the
signal will will be boosted by by a
factor of l so now you only need the n
times row times l to diverge
um
like many people including quite a few
in this room have have worked on
variations of of this
assumption and corresponding methods and
the theory
so um what i
try to do like after seeing that uh
monkey bring co-expression networks like
i try to uh remove the layer-wise
positivity assumption so like the try to
understand how or investigate how we can
aggregate multiple layers without this
positivity assumption
and again how like without this
assumption
do we still have this uh
factor of l boost in the single strands
are you assuming the block structure for
multi layers are the same
yes
in this presentation we assume they are
the same and in the paper we slightly
relax this requirements they are allowed
to change slightly and there's a more
challenging question that they they
change smoothly over time that is uh
current work
right it could be for example that one
of the beasts
is concentrated on the
near the diagonal so this inner
community the correction are stronger
and the next being yes the
the bees can be generally
and it still has because of my voice if
it's the opposite and you add things up
just exactly yeah
so here is actually corresponding to
your comments
if we imagine these bis are generated
from uniform distribution subject to
symmetry we added them up you could just
completely flat matrix there's no
uh grouping information there
so the first approach of course i
computer student i i considered mle
right so the
something close to mle is is least
square so you basically minimize over
all possible
b's and the g's like the the residual
sum square of the realized adjacency
matrix and their expected value
right and uh
like the analysis and the behavior of
mle and thesis where they are very
similar at least from my observation and
we choose to like uh present these
square here for another reason i will
uh
mention later so if we do this like
suppose we can at least approximately uh
globally solve
this computationally invisible problem
what we can uh
say is that
the the the fraction of mis-clustered
nodes is bounded by
some logarithm term divided by this n
times rho not times l but l square root
so instead of that linear in l boost we
have a square root of boost
uh that's about uh least square and the
the the main
the result is not about at least the
squares at least the score is just a
start so then i i tried to like
tweak the least square estimate a little
bit uh see if i can find like more
computationally feasible methods and
what i did is i i reparametrize the
membership vector to this corresponding
what i call normalized membership matrix
essentially it has n rows and k columns
each column corresponding to that
indicator of that the case community
with
with entries normalized that you have
this column
unit norm
so
and you just go through a bunch of basic
algebra
similar to your total variance
decomposition in analysis of variance
the least squares problem can be
approximately rewritten
first to a maximization problem so the
the least square problem is this
minimizing
within cluster residual sum square and
this maximizing problem corresponds to
the corresponding
between
class
sum square the difference sum square and
then this approximation
is comes from the fact that these a's
they share roughly the same
leading eigenvectors right and and
then you can arrive from the left to
right you can see that the right
dominates the left but because g
corresponds to the common leading
eigenvectors for all these a's so we
have this uh
approximation in the middle
so what what what does this reduce to
this reduce to the an eigenvector
problem of the sum
of the squared adjacency matrices
so the natural thing to do is now we're
in a good shape to do spectral
clustering so so we just
relax the requirement of of we have to
consider normalize the the membership
matrix
then we just consider all what's or
normal the the membership matrices after
normalization they're they're also
normal so if we relax the feasible
statistic or
what's the normal matrices then we are
just in the classical
we can call it pca or a spectral
clustering of matrix and then apply
the any
clustering algorithm to the to the rows
of this matrix u
so this is
like vanilla
spectral clustering applied to the the
sum of squared against the matrices
perhaps you could imagine like we can
start directly from
this approach and i just would like to
explain it actually has a pretty close
connection to the least square
perspective
so
now we're talking about spectral
clustering we are all familiar with it
so only two sentences
to summarize how it works so suppose you
have your data which which is a it can
be written as a signal plus noise so s
is the signal its leading eigenvectors
contains useful information and n is a
noise so we want to use the eigenvectors
of a to approximate those of s
so that we hope the eigenvectors of a
contain similar information so a
sufficient condition
is that the eigen gap of s meaning that
the difference between the smallest
useful eigenvalue and the largest to use
the second value the difference between
them dominates the operating norm of the
noise so then we can use standard
perturbation theory to show that the
um the eigenvectors of a are almost as
good as those of s
so now i tried to
analyze this spectral clustering for the
sum of squared adjacencies but what i do
is also a
fairly standard error decomposition so i
let this pl be the expected value of the
adjacency matrix at layer l and their
difference is called el that's just the
noise matrix at layer l
and then i expand the square
so the first term pl square of course is
our uh
is our signal it contains k
large eigenvectors and
the others are almost zero and they they
are squared so the signal adds up
at the speed linear in l over the layers
and the second and the third terms are a
cross product of uh or matrix product
of this signal and noise so when we add
them up we know that they are
they are mean zero so use something
uh pretty standard matrix bernstein we
would hope that this part increases at
the speed of square root l
because you just add up a bunch of zero
mean independent matrices
so the problematic part is the last part
it's the square
of the noise matrix and we know for sure
it's always positive semi-definite and
it it gives you the bias and it grows at
the speed linear in l which is the same
as the single this is
problematic
right so um
now so what we do is we we just take a
closer look
at this squared noise matrix and if we
just expand the square entry wise we can
see that
entry wise the expected value of the
squared noise matrix is still zero for
off diagonal entries
because you are summing up
like the products of independent zero
mean
random variables and the only problem is
on the diagonal
so if i expand the diagonal entry of the
squared noise matrix
i i get up just
it's a it's the sum of
a bunch of centered bernoulli squared
okay and
the the problem of bernoulli variable is
that if you if you square the bernoulli
variable because
in these three terms p square is small
because we know that the rho is small
and a times p
acts like p squared if you take its
expected value but a square
is a
so there
that has a higher order of magnitude if
the if the
sparsity is low
so now
so now we basically uh
nail down the from the problematic term
and luckily this term
can be computed from beta
so when you sum up overall case
that red term
the the high order bias term corresponds
to the degree of node i in that layer
so
the the the natural thing to do seems to
be just remove
the degree
from that squared matrix because i don't
need to know that error matrix and i
only needed to know the a matrix to
calculate this this leading bias term so
like i'm writing it this way but in
practice we just
square all the adjacencies in all layers
add them up zero out the diagonal
so how does this work
well i'm showing you a very simple
simulation i have more comprehensive
simulations in the paper so i i choose
these settings of b so we have like 30
layers and the b's are generated like
randomly picked between these two so
these beads are children so that like
the the the simple
summing up
which is the green line
and the the
uh the original
sum of square spectral clustering which
is the orange line
both of these will fail at the same time
and the blue line is is the bias removed
the diagonal removed spectral clustering
so we can see that from so the the
x-axis is the row
the
density parameter so from the left when
it's very sparse so nothing works and on
the on the left the
the orange curve starts to go down so
that means like the the effect of the
bias matters less when we have denser
networks
but there is the regime in the in the
middle where the bias term actually does
matter and removing it helps a lot
so
this talk is pretty simple and comparing
to others but i like simple stuff the
analysis is also
quite straightforward if we just follow
the
the previous error decomposition
and we know that the squared singular
matrix
they they share the same roughly the
same
leading eigenvectors and they are all
squared so they sum up
they grow at the speed of l and
these cross terms grows at speed
square root l and
what we are able to show like maybe the
hardest part is is part three that after
removing the diagonal right the squared
error matrices when you add them up
they grow up at the speed
of square root tail
so um
so the simplified version of this
theorem is
okay like i'm simplifying all other
aspects of the problem like the the
balance the community and the constant
number of communities
you can relax
all those with with more bookkeeping and
the requirement on the connectivity so
now what so what i needed is is the
average of the squared connectivity
matrices bl
is bounded away from zero so like
requiring the the square to be bounded
away from zero is like um
essentially dropping the positivity
because after square we know their
positive semi-definite and
this is just requiring in all directions
like a constant fraction of the layers
pick some of those subspaces up
and and
so then the
the error rate is basically
the inverse of this quantity
that means uh the fraction
of misclustered nodes is upper bounded
by this
square root of logarithms divided by n
times rho times
l square square root so like compared to
the to the least square result it's a
logarithm factor improvement but more
importantly this is achieved by a very
simple estimator it's just a
spectral clustering applied to
diagonal removed
because typically
right so you need
one over rho times n for
mean squared but you need an extra log
if you want left string to work because
otherwise the largest degrees
yes
so by removing this guy you actually get
better respect for trust and then
these squares that sort of counter into
it well so uh i have to admit that the
the results for for least square may not
be sharp in the dependence on the
logarithmic terms
so so so that part like
there's some artifacts in the argument
that generates the additional logarithm
terms and also about
high degree so the this removing is only
diagonal the high degree
nodes are are still in so i would expect
that like if you actually use some like
graph laplacian version of this you can
this may work with it
can i follow up with that
same question right so you can do this
in the laplacian you can do this in
regular original classes such as power
people
so
how does that compare with like other
ways of dealing with the data
it's like regularization
yeah i i haven't
because
there this is like how how do we use
graph laplacian for for this problem i
think that's an interesting question
which i haven't investigated but here
the questions are like the first
question i would consider
how do we use graph graph laplacian do
we square first and then laplace unit or
we laplacian it first and then square so
it's unclear
attending conferences
[Music]
so it seems to me at least like
heuristically when you square the dnc
matrix you turn
a matrix which is off-diagonal to and a
diagonal matrix right so you're looking
at the this assortative
network for example but if you square
the adjacency matrix then it will become
a diagonal matrix so it will become like
a um
uh authoritative case right so is that
the heuristic behind squaring you know
well uh i actually i'm not sure because
the
like assorted assortativity
seems to appear more often in social
science uh and in
genomics it's probably less
likely to be the case and here i guess
the the reason to take square is mainly
like algebraic just to to get all the
the eigenvalues to to be non-negative
right but compared to the um the simple
case where you just sum up the
urgency matrix that would run into
problem if you have like associative
right associative but if you square them
then this
this assortative network will
will turn into a sortative network so
maybe you can apply the um
laplacian after you square that
okay yeah okay thanks for the suggestion
thanks for all the questions
i wonder am i not right that
an interpretation
of this sum of a ij's sum of a squared
is simply the total number of common
neighbors of i and j
in the two networks
yes
and then the diagonal is simply the
degree yes
so so in some sense it's clear that
that's something that can't help you
right because because it's tells you
nothing about the communities
yeah yeah
yeah and and uh so like
like
without the error decomposition we don't
know like we know it's useless but like
with the error decomposition we know
it's actually harmful so it's better to
be removed well
there's a precedent if you want
it say things estimating like like
decimating you want to estimate
the integral of the square of this right
and what you do is you start a kernel
density estimate you square it
and then you integrate and that turns
out to be a use statistic
but there's a part of the u statistic
which is analogous to the diagonal which
has nothing to do with anything it's a
constant
so you have to subtract it out
oh yeah
yeah apparently
it's this similar phenomenon
thank you peter
all right
i guess first you have a couple myths
great so uh
these are just uh the the details for
each component of the error terms and
the first one is what i call the
generalize the bernstein's inequality
this is actually the technique is
nothing fancy basically it's more about
like bookkeeping how to use like joel
drops
matrix for instance inequality in
various vector and
and matrix forms but like i i just found
like this particular form
a pretty like a nice looking like
intermediate like corollary where like
if we are familiar with bernstein's
inequalities they're like uh
in the in the denominator there's a
variance term but if we're doing the
matrix form where the x's are mean zero
matrices and the h's are fixed
coefficients and and the variance term
is actually uh governed jointly by
forbiddenious norm of h and operator
norm of h square and
and the the
the corresponding like a scaling part in
the bernstein's inequalities actually
comes from
the the maximum row
norms of these edges
what's like okay the technically most
involved part is the
is the square term so after removing
the diagonal
then these squared errors grows that's
the the speed of square root of l
because now every like except the
diagonal which is small after removing
the degrees and then everywhere else is
zero mean so we should hope something
like this to to happen and the main
ingredient in the proof
is just two two rungs of of decoupling
so i
i realized that this is essentially a
quadratic form
of of zero mean matrices so i looked up
hands and writing inequality i had to
like adapt the proof there and then like
essentially
finding the the most relevant
piece of reference of the decoupling
technique and then
i was able to to get this
and also
this is a more general form of the hands
and writing inequality written for
subgaussian tails essentially like these
are
a sum of sequence centered
matrix quadratic forms and
i show it they grow at the speed of
square root l because you sum over this
q norm squared over l and then you take
a square root outside so this is a
slightly more general
form of this
hands and right matrix version
now
let's uh take a quick look at um
at the
gene co-expression network data set i
mentioned in the beginning we have close
to 8 000 genes and the 10 layers
from 40 days
in in brio to two years after birth
and um
and we use the k equals eight by screen
plot actually all these pre-processing
number choices we made we checked the
stability
of our results with respect to these
choices such as how do we define an edge
between two genes and how many
communities we assume there are and the
result seems to be
to be stable so this perhaps the screen
is hard to see but um
i'm showing the three time periods
showing in the beginning of the
of the slides and now for all eight like
8000 genes
so as we can see in early days right the
uh
the cluster one two they are more
actively connected and as time moves on
the other the the the clusters in the
middle are more active and the at the
end the last the the number seven
is the only active one
and and these community structures are
actually pretty common across time and
also there is a big chunk of genes
almost a half of all genes that doesn't
show
like any
significantly
like high or low
or they're significantly low but not
significantly high connectivities across
time so that corresponds to a big group
each node is a king and then we measure
um
like what
so yes there there is a
there's a standard the pre-processing in
in such uh genomics study uh you take
the the correlation between two genes
and raise them to
like a certain power and
and the threshold it so like if the
correlation is high you claim
there is an edge and if the absolute
correlation is low you claim there's no
edge so did you express that location
the monkey brain oh yes this is in
in that medial prefrontal cortex of
monkey brain
no because like
they are from multiple mountains and
they happen to like uh spanish 10
different time periods and they have
good registration to match them
yeah because all you need is
like
i don't know how the spatial matching is
but
i guess they just take the tissue from
the same area in the brain but like then
all we need to know is it is the how the
genes
are are expressed so you look at
differential
expressions
in correlation correlation
slash which gives you the adjacency
[Music]
yeah that's right
and and then um like the first three
communities they they have very uh like
small p values in the gene ontology
mapping and honestly i know
a little about the science behind them
but like at least this shows some
evidence
that like these
groups are are doing something and
and not surprisingly the last one like
the the
the biggest cluster which shows almost
no connectivity
at any time point is it is none and um
so
this picture is basically another angle
to look at uh the temporals uh like
activities of all these different uh
communities so at early stage
the
community number one is this highly
connected and as time
moves on like communities three four
five six and until the the the last time
point community seven is the highest
connected and the community eighties is
pretty flat so this suggests if like we
we want to do a follow-up study we
probably should
like focus on the first seven and remove
the last one
okay so a couple of uh notes about uh
what's next so i'm i'm really uh like uh
curious about the optimality of the
square root l boost of signal when we
drop the positivity conjecture sorry uh
the the condition and my first
conjecture is that uh
if if we don't worry about computational
feasibility we should still be able to
find a way to get
the
capital l the linear signal boost for
example this is like my guess like
conjecture like
we just do this um optimization problem
to find the best linear aggregation of
all layers and then apply uh spectral
clustering but the second conjunction i
guess maybe more interesting is that uh
if if
we only consider polynomial time for
example this computational barrier
threat of work if we assume that like
planted clique
or this tensor version of planted clique
is hard
then
this is probably the best we can do and
also
i'm also
working with uh student to to see like
use the probability tools like those
hands and writes and the matrix bursting
inequalities
tools to to study similar scenarios but
like we have varying
memberships up over time but smoothly
and slowly so like how do we do like a
bias variance trade-off
similar to this um
like non-parametric
regression
and also estimating k i
i have not talked about this but uh i
guess there are
possible like uh common solutions like
cross-validation or spectral methods and
also there is also the question how how
does l come into play when we try to
estimate k
that's it
thanks
[Applause]
one lee question before the break
so in the case when you have the block
structure being the same isn't that
equivalent to have multiple like flips
for each edge
what did that mean something
the b's are different so you have
different probabilities yes as as we can
see the the the connectivity density
changes very very significantly from
time to time yeah i know if it's the
same so you're you're assuming that the
probabilities change from layer to layer
the probability change between edges
yeah so if we don't assume that
if we assume that the probabilities are
the same then you add them up would be
the best thing to do
okay so you do assume they're different
okay
so let's thank the two speakers for the
first session again
next station will start at 10 40.
so the cost